[Music]
foreign
hey everybody it's Sunday
look at your little mustache and beard
he was talking to the side he's talking
about last night he's like I have to be
careful about like uh drinking now
because he doesn't want all stuff like
getting it you can see your [ __ ]
mustache Yeah well yeah everybody that
has had mustaches all this time were
like well duh yeah you gotta [ __ ] your
head back like that
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's not as good you
could get a straw you came for this you
can't drink with recklessness
you can't not like that because of the
facial hair not back in the Roman Empire
days when you don't have these facial
hair you know what I mean I'm all
Germanic Barbarian now
I'm gonna get you a Bendy straw yeah I
went to the uh
how many people we got in here now I
don't know okay
I went to the uh biker bar again today
they had um
birthday party 29th Euro 29th birthday
party
for um uh undercover stripper and all
her undercover stripper friends and
their moms who were undercover strippers
too I could tell they were all I knew
they were all strippers but they were
trying to like pretend they were
strippers undercover
and I was there Southern Southern as
[ __ ] [ __ ] 70 of them under the
[ __ ] under the under the height the
five feet they're all a little short got
it on video to prove it I'm not [ __ ]
lying little shorties undercover
strippers would be a great band yeah
undercover strippers yeah
somebody get on that yeah
yeah she's 29 she looked like she was
about 18. and then then the younger ones
look like they were like 14 or 15 but
they were like you know 20. well I hope
so yeah otherwise they should not and
then they had they had some of them that
were like then they had like the mama
bear who was like a mama just strippers
and [ __ ]
she's a stripper and her daughters are
stripper type thing Mama Bear was
probably about 45 50.
she's still looking good though but you
could you could just tell
okay and they were handing out free food
but it was it was [ __ ]
I was like man I can't eat that it was
like it was like [ __ ] super sweet
cake you know yeah you didn't have any
cake no I didn't have any cake
and then it had biscuits and gravy
that's your favorite yeah I know but
they had tomatoes in the [ __ ] grave
and the thing is is that biscuits they
had tomatoes in it which I've never seen
that
and then they they planted are they from
I don't know
and then it had uh and it was in a crock
pot all right
so I'm like looking around a little bit
like I don't know what these people's
houses look like you know what I mean so
I'm about to eat out of there I didn't
eat I didn't eat out of there I don't
blame you they made that [ __ ] up there
at their house I don't think I'd be
eating at a place called The Oasis Bar
I've seen that place from the outside I
wouldn't want to eat anything oh no uh
uh um the owner will [ __ ] bring in
prime rib and all kinds of [ __ ] and give
it out for free oh okay no it's nice
yeah and it just like at the top it
doesn't [ __ ] announce it it's just
prime rib today you're surprised put it
out on the prime rib yeah put it out on
a steam table and everything man all you
can eat [ __ ] meat
yeah I got that [ __ ] on video I was
[ __ ] videos I believe you what you
think somebody's gonna come back and say
I was sharing the evidence I was sharing
it with sod he was up in Saudi Arabia
and he happened to be awake and we were
[ __ ] talking over a thing that's a
son look at this [ __ ] he goes oh man
that looks good dude yeah show them the
prime rib yeah it's like eating that
[ __ ] Moss Eisley star Port [ __ ]
you know a [ __ ] den of [ __ ]
villainy and evil [ __ ] murder Hornet
cameras everywhere murder Hornet said
Tom has truck nuts on his moped
Oracle says Hey Y'all hey sorry I've
been around much I have an elderly Kitty
who's been wanting more attention yeah I
mean you know we know how that goes I
mean our Kitty's not elderly but she
does always want attention that's for
sure Danny Rowling said I wish they
would turn Stephen King's book from a
Buick eight into a made for TV film
because it takes place in Pennsylvania
and not Maine I didn't love that book
though I kind of felt like it was too
similar to Christine you know what I
mean like I know it has like a different
thing but it's still essentially a
haunted car you know what I'm saying all
right here's birthday girl
that's it
[ __ ] getting the glare
well and she's blowing out the candles
blowing out to Canada like I told you
they're they're not none of them were
above five feet tall that was Mama Bear
right there
right there and
then the dog walks in then the dog walks
in the dog was [ __ ] begging
the dog was begging all day
yeah
then the kiss in the stripper pole
yeah
so that's what I did
that's what I did today and then they
take pictures
aspiring to be on the stripper pole
see I I could read I you know I
understand what they're doing
taking pictures with the stripper pole
fascinating yeah so uh anyway
let's talk about
this movie yeah so
um yeah okay now I'm fascinated by I
think a lot of people are I'm fascinated
by Stephen King adaptations and we've
talked before about how there's kind of
like a spectrum of like there's really
really fantastic ones and there's more
fantastic ones than people say you know
what I mean because I know that there's
kind of like people are like oh Stephen
King adaptations oh they always suck no
they don't there's a lot of really
really good ones but some of them do
suck absolutely
but there's a really I think the
majority of them fall into the same uh
area of the spectrum that this one falls
into where it's like this one is fine
but
it's not really anything to write home
about you know what I mean and it's just
kind of like so it falls into this kind
of like vast chasm in the middle of just
like really mediocre
adaptations that everybody kind of
forgot about I actually kind of forgot
about it until I was scrolling through
Amazon and I was like oh yeah I remember
they did make a movie version of that
and it's like I think I saw it but I
didn't remember anything about it so I
was kind of curious to watch it again
um also fascinatingly uh they made two
sequels to this which is crazy yeah but
first one wasn't that good but yeah well
the thing about it is like Children of
the Corn which came out in 1984. that
made like [ __ ] how many sequels to
that today but like a ridiculous amount
like way more well I mean any number of
sequels to that movie is more than there
had to be but they were like way more
than you would the first one was okay as
something you'd rented it yeah the first
one was okay I didn't mind them it was
cheesy but that's all right you've
rented that [ __ ] from Blockbuster when
you were a kid it's all right yeah
that's what it was for
but like [ __ ] six of them well it's
the same thing with [ __ ] transfers I
think it might have been more than six
of them Children of the Corn uh sequels
sorry I haven't seen any of them so I
can't really transfers I think there's
four or five of them six of them
somebody is watching these movies God
damn it it's like otherwise they can't
well I mean look at all and I'm not
[ __ ] on like puppet master or
anything like that because the first
puppet master is actually like really
good but it's like how many [ __ ]
Puppet Master movies do they have now
how many Amityville movies do they have
now
19. although those aren't really like
related because Amityville was based on
like a true crime case and it's just
like a house so you don't need rights to
it so you can just like make whatever
[ __ ] movie you want just slap the
Amityville name on it so that's not
really exactly the same thing but it's
weird that this that Sometimes they come
back like actually had two sequels which
were called Sometimes they come back
again of course and sometimes they come
back for more
so there was that so I was curious like
I said I watched the thing I I said look
at this look at this uh I've had this
obviously for a really long time in the
night shift this actually fell off
uh and this is the uh this is a book
that Sometimes they come back the
original short story is in it actually
was first published in Cavalier I guess
it was just like a titty mag like back
in the 70s and then it was later
collected in this now the short story is
actually really good I was Stephen King
I like his novels and stuff like that
but I'm a big advocate of his short he's
really good at writing short stories you
know what I mean like his short stories
Kick-Ass so sometimes they come back as
like a really good short story and I was
curious I read it like a bunch of times
when I was younger but I hadn't read it
for several years so I specifically like
read it like right before we did like
before right before we came live because
I wanted to know like how I'm watching
the movie and I'm like this seems kind
of like the story but I couldn't
remember like all the finer details and
there are like some significant
differences but I'll get into that in a
little bit
so what happened with this movie
evidently from everything that I could
determine this movie was actually
originally supposed to be
um a portion you remember the that
actually pretty good like Stephen King
uh Anthology film cat's eye from 85.
yeah it was not with Drew Barrymore yeah
and it had like three stories that like
quitters Inc and the ledge and what was
that other one like about the cat named
general you know with the little uh
troll or whatever yeah that's actually a
really good movie and we reviewed it I
think one of you guys like sent it to us
as a matter of fact
um but yeah so sometimes they come back
was supposed to be the fourth segment in
that movie as far as I could determine
but Dino DiLaurentis who is the producer
on this
decided that Sometimes they come back
was actually good enough and substantial
enough a story that it needed a whole
movie now I think this movie was made
for TV but I don't know where they
showed it at first I thought it felt
like I made yeah I think it was
um made for TV but I don't know where it
aired first I don't know if it was made
for cable because it came out in 1991.
so I don't know if it showed on like a
network or if it was cable or this is
made in TV imma be this is made for TV
I'm gonna be a little more lenient on it
yeah this is actually it's actually not
bad for a made-for-tv movie and like
actually the Practical effects like some
of the uh like corpse effects and stuff
like that were actually pretty good for
1991 and for my only complaint is that
the movie for me was a little bit Bland
it is a little bit I kind of feel like
okay the thing about it like there's a
lot going on in the short story and the
short story is actually a lot uh darker
like I said I'll get into some of the
differences because I had forgotten
about them
but I don't think I mean the short story
is only like 30 pages long so I don't
really think I feel like the movie had a
lot of padding in it that it didn't
really need to have like I think this
would have worked better had it been
like a 20 30 minute segment in an
anthology film it probably would have
kicked ass because it's a good story I
was watching it and I was just getting a
few minutes into it and I was like I see
where they're going I see what kind of
movie this is going to be
um it was a middling [ __ ] King
movie
and the effort was like to Pat it out it
was kind of like that last damn vampire
movie that we saw that one was actually
a little more exciting was that one that
we saw uh oh the return to Salem return
to Salem's locked I thought that I
thought that was awful but at least I
had at least I kind of remembered a lot
of that
I remember it because it was terrible
yeah this one is maybe the bigger sin
because it's like it's okay yeah but on
a bland yeah it's just kind of like
there's nothing wrong with it
necessarily it's just like not all that
exciting and it's not
uh you know anything to write home about
like I said everything in it is just
fine everything's fine it's just middle
of the road like the acting is fine yeah
you know there's good actors that
there's Tim Matheson's in it uh Brooke
Adams is in it um you know she was
actually in dead zone the David
cronenberg's Death Zone adaptation uh
which is a lot better Stephen King
adaptation than this one but I don't
want to [ __ ] on it too much because like
I said it's fine it's just nothing
special and it's easy to see why this is
one that kind of like slips through the
cracks where some people are just like
oh my God I forgot that they even
adapted that one like back in 1991
so um so if you haven't seen it like the
story kind of concerns uh Tim Matheson
plays this guy who's a teacher like Jim
Norman what's the matter with you no oh
you're back there like [ __ ] up
thrashing around I'm [ __ ] up oh yeah
well I'm sorry let me leave no I'm just
no I'm just asking what's going on back
there I'm just reacting to what you're
saying and I'm going oh okay yeah okay I
just I didn't know I never know no no if
I'm you're [ __ ] up the show I'll
leave you're just trash it around and I
didn't know what you're doing but uh but
yeah so uh so he's a teacher or he takes
a teaching job like back at his old in
his old Hometown uh because he can't
because something happened like he was
teaching in Chicago and something
happened like he lost his temper and
they actually say what happened in the
story but they don't really tell you in
the movie it was just kind of like oh he
lost it you're just assuming that he
like you know punched a student in the
face or something like that
um which is actually kind of the same
thing kind of the same thing happened in
The Shining now that I'm thinking about
it maybe Stephen King because Stephen
King taught school for a while too and
I'm just kind of like did he punch a
student and he just because he he's
putting that in his stories I'm just I'm
just saying I just wanted to come well I
kind of feel like every free teachers
wanted to you always want to just look
at Stephen King there's no power behind
that man
weak well he could have like Chuck
something yeah winged a bucket
somebody's head or something stupid [ __ ]
him up
but I don't know I'm just I'm just
saying it's probably like but like I
said I'm not a teacher but I had I know
some teachers and I had a teacher in my
family so um yeah they usually do kind
of want to like punch especially if
they're teaching like teenagers yeah you
know what I mean like so I could totally
see that but yeah so he got in trouble
in Chicago so he has to go like take a
teaching job back in his old hometown
and this starts bringing back memories
of his brother getting murdered when he
was like when he was nine and his older
brother was 12. and the whole thing is
like you know there's the the
stereotypical bullies that are in a lot
of Stephen King stories that are like
these 50s Greaser type Tufts with like
the the car with the flames and all that
kind of stuff and they all have
switchblades and little Peg jeans and
leather you know little ducks ass
haircuts and [ __ ] like that because like
I said that's that's when Stephen King
was young so yeah white kids that never
existed in the universe I grew up in
well you're younger than Stephen King
they probably didn't exist back then I
yeah maybe they did I don't know but
well and the thing about it though is
that maybe they're taking it from like
pop culture because that was going on a
lot in movies in the 50s like little but
I don't know the same but I don't know
if it was in real life because I wasn't
alive then it's the same [ __ ] in the
80s whenever they had to have some Thugs
and troublemakers it was always punk
rock kids
even their real punk rockers yeah we've
talked about that before like never real
punk rock hits 99.99 they were the ones
getting picked on yeah not the ones that
were picking on other people they put
them in there because they didn't want
to look racist by putting anybody else
in there they needed some kind of
minority Misfits but [ __ ] they better be
white so let's put the [ __ ] white
let's put the white [ __ ] um punk rock
kids in there those punk rock kids
weren't troublemakers to be honest I
think like the best example of what more
like what it was really like or more
approaching what it was really like was
um maybe some of John Hughes movies like
Pretty in Pink where it was kind of like
the rich douchey like like not
necessarily jocks but like the rich kids
and [ __ ] like that that were picking on
like the poor kids and the weirdos that
was kind of more accurate than punk rock
I mean at least where I went to school
that was a lot more accurate I think
that's why I related to pretty and pink
so much I'm like yeah that's about
because I went because I was poor and I
went to a school they won't talk about
that because that's what Columbine was
all about that's what was really
happening
let's get there [ __ ] I know people went
to went to that high school it's a bunch
of rich kids picking on people that kids
that weren't quite as Rich even though
they had money too
and those dudes that shot the place up
were
the kids that weren't quite as rich as
the other ones yeah and uh kept getting
[ __ ] with so they hated the school
want to destroy it and all the people
they were they were evil though too
those kids you know well obviously yeah
they shot a bunch of people that didn't
deserve it it didn't deserve it you know
but yeah so um regardless of whether the
50s Greece or uh bullies existed in real
life or not uh they stab um his brother
to death and I guess like they never got
caught and so basically like after he
grows up like he still he has like
nightmares about it
and then when he goes back to his Old
Town
um some weird [ __ ] starts to happen like
he has this one class at the end of the
day that's kind of all you know I don't
want to be mean but like all all the
dumb kids like well it's mostly like the
jocks that just want to keep their stay
on the football team so it's supposed to
be like an easy class for them
um so yeah so he's teaching that class
and there's a bunch of [ __ ] in
there and there's a couple kids in there
that are okay though but then like they
turn up like dying in ways that could be
construed as like an accident or maybe
suicide and each time one of them dies
another one of the guys like from his
past like turns up as like a transfer
student from Milford High and looking
exactly the same as they did back then
um even though he knows that they're all
dead
uh so yeah they're basically like
they're not even ghosts really even
though there's a scene where he's sees
them like all sitting in the bathroom
and he looks and they don't have
Reflections but they're clearly like
physically there so I guess they're more
like revenants but they've kind of
because they're not really zombies but
they can like look like corpsey or they
can look normal you know what I mean so
they're kind of like quasi-super natural
I guess but yeah so obviously nobody
believes him that all of these students
that are dying in his class are getting
replaced by these dead people
and then it all kind of like comes to a
head so when I was reading the story
like I said the story is actually really
good but I had forgotten how much it
differed from the movie because when I
was watching the movie like I said I
hadn't read the story in a long time and
I was like yeah this seems like kind of
what happened in the story that I
remember but when I read the story again
like you know half an hour ago I was
like oh man that's a lot different in
the movie
um you know he has a wife like he does
in the in the uh in the story but in the
story they don't have a kid in the movie
they have a kid so I guess they wanted
to make like you know putting kids in
danger that's always kind of to upped
attention or whatever but they don't
have a kid in the in the short story
also
um in the movie they show Jim like
riding after the first kid that gets
killed uh whose name is Billy and they
show him like he sees it happen like the
car like with the Flames like um
like runs Billy off the road like on his
bicycle and he falls like off this
bridge or whatever but nobody sees the
car but him and Billy saw it but Billy's
dead now and
um in the story
Billy does die he does get run off the
road but it but he didn't see it happen
like it happened somewhere else like
when the school was on break or
something like that so he didn't
actually see it happen but the cop tells
him it's like oh there was a black car
that said Snake Eyes on the side that
ran him off the road but he didn't see
it happen
same thing with like the next girl that
died who I think in the movie is named
Kate like in the story she's named Kathy
and in the story she actually gets she
either Falls or gets pushed off a
building and in the movie she's like
she's found hanging in a barn and
everybody thinks it's suicide but he
knows it's murder because he dreamed
about it like the night before it
happened and so they subsequently think
that he's maybe responsible for the
crime I don't really think that happened
that didn't seem to happen in the story
where they blamed him for the murders
you know what I mean but in the movie
they do also in the story spoiler alert
uh the hoods like back from the dead
kill his wife
they run her over
they like run her up they hit her like
when she's walking home from somewhere
like they run her over and uh she dies
so in the movie like no it's and the
movie is a lot more
uplifting I guess to a to a degree where
I think it's like a little bit too
cheesy and I get that they were trying
to I guess because it was made for TVs
they didn't want to go like too [ __ ]
dark with it but in the story not only
does his wife die but he defeats the you
know the ghosts or the revenants or
whatever by essentially
summoning a demon to take them back to
hell like he cuts off his fingers and
does the whole thing like in the movie
where they go back to the um to the
train tunnel like where the first
original murder happened and they
reenact it and stuff so that's the same
but
in the movie they just have like the
ghost of his brother come back and be
like yeah I'll take care of this from
now on or whatever but in the story like
the demon comes back and kind of looks
like his brother but it's not his
brother it's a demon that he summoned
and he did it on purpose like
to take the to make them go away you
know what I'm saying so so I thought the
end of the movie was like a little
schmaltzy
you don't mean like we're uh you know
where the brother comes back and he's
just like why are you growing up now
like and because he doesn't realize that
27 years has gone by and he's come back
to heaven and he's like oh I'll come
back to heaven and see you and boy I
gotta stay here and blah blah so it's
all that kind of like it's schmalty like
the ending was kind of by the time the
end of the movie had come around I
totally lost interest I didn't give a
[ __ ] it was
um like I said Bland uh I didn't realize
it was a made for TV production probably
would have
been better had you been watching it on
television for free you probably would
have had a different
especially back in those days
but there's just nothing really visual
or cinematic about the movie there's no
Cinema in it
it's a it's telling instead of showing a
lot of the time it's um like you said
padding there's a bunch of padding in it
yeah
um
it's just
oh if you ask me only if you're a real
hardcore Stephen King movie fan I
wouldn't bother with it outside that
there's a bunch of other other ones that
are a lot better
yeah Salem's lot's a lot better yeah I
mean this one like I said it's kind of
in that really really large middle tier
of ones that are not terrible but
they're also really not really all that
special or all that memorable and it's
forgettable like it's a decent
adaptation but I kind of feel like if
you were gonna adapt the movie and maybe
like they couldn't do it because it was
for TV and like I said the story is a
lot darker than what you see on screen
like it's similar but the way it ends is
different like I said in the story his
wife gets killed
um you know but and she doesn't in the
movie but I don't know like I just feel
like maybe I mean nowadays if they did
an adaptation they would probably do it
just like the story like rather than
trying to [ __ ] now the thing about it
the guy that directed this um Tom
McLaughlin he's directed a few movies
but not all that many I think the best
the best known one that he's directed
was
um Friday the 13th part six
Jason lives I think that's part six
right now see this is directed by John
Carpenter when Carpenter was on point
this would have been a lot better but
like I said it might have been it might
have been just budget constraints and
you know yeah time and I mean
given the limitations of being made for
TV where it's like it can't be too gross
you can't have any nudity or swearing or
it can't be too dark or anything like
that
given those constraints you know in the
budget was probably really low it's
actually not bad and like I said when
they do
um you know when the uh the bullies or
whatever the murderers when they have
like their corpse makeup that actually
looks pretty cool for a TV movie from
1991. I mean you know it's not bad so
you know I don't want to [ __ ] on it too
much but like I said it's just kind of
like
I wanted to watch it again because I was
like well sometimes you know they've
made so many adaptations of Stephen
King's stories that sometimes I forget
that it was like oh yeah I forgot they
adapted that one and then sometimes I
watch it again and I'm like oh man that
was like way better than I remembered so
I wanted to see if this one was one of
those because I think I had the same
thing happen like when I watched I
re-watched
thinner like not too long ago and I was
like and it's not that's not a great
movie either but it's better than I
remembered it being the dark half is a
lot better than I remember I kind of
want to do a movie retrospective on that
I think I put it in the poll or it's
gonna be in an upcoming poll like I
remember thinking it was okay when it
came out but I liked that movie I think
I saw it in the theater and I've seen it
a couple times since then time time's
been kind to it yeah it's still real
watch sometimes that happens like I said
you know sometimes you have something
like Children of the Corn which I'm not
saying is like not watchable because it
is but it's very it's very very 80s and
it's just very very cheesy and like some
of this stuff hasn't really dated all
that well and it looks real cheap some
of the stuff it does some stuff looks
real cheap even though I'm pretty sure
that got a theatrical release yeah it
did yeah
they were talking about everybody liked
it I didn't see it I don't think I saw
it in the theater I think I saw it on
cable like a year or two later
but because I think I was only 12 so my
parents would have had to take me to see
that if I'd seen it what year was that
again 84 84. yeah
I thought it was Oh I thought it was
later than that but I guess it was no it
was 84. yeah and I mean because I
remember I remember it being all the in
fangoria and stuff like that but yeah so
I'm always kind of curious to watch ones
that kind of get got forgotten about
because I kind of feel like to a lesser
extent
um a lot of people don't talk about
Christine like the adaptation of
Christine even though it was John
[ __ ] Carpenter yeah and I [ __ ]
love Christine I love the adaptation
that's a classy movie and I feel like a
lot of people don't like don't remember
that one when they're talking about oh
the best Stephen King adaptations I
absolutely think that was one of the
best ones it's real well made yeah I
like it a lot um the best of the cheap
ones are uh Dead Zone and Fire Starter
those are the best of the cheap ones
dead zone is so good but that's
Cronenberg see yeah yeah yeah I kind of
feel like for Stephen King adaptations
to work you have to get a really big ass
director you gotta have Carpenter you
gotta have Chrome Berg you gotta have
Frank Darabont you got to have somebody
that is vibing no okay who did Fire
Starter um because I like Firestarter
[ __ ] I thought it was pretty good it
just totally went out of my brain it
aged pretty well it did we saw it
recently yeah it's still real watchable
yeah because remember we watched it
again like after we saw the new one
because I wanted to see like uh what the
difference was but yeah so I feel like I
don't know this to me
Sometimes they come back it's better
than
uh for example Sleepwalkers which was
terrible yeah um I mean some people like
it just because it's terrible and I get
that I do I see you Christine is almost
up there with uh uh [ __ ] Carrie I
would or I would argue that Christine is
it might be a little bit better is I
don't know I think Carrie is better but
not by much I think Christina is good
and I think Christine like gets I don't
know maybe to this day it's maybe it's
not as underrated as I think it is but I
do kind of feel like when people are
bringing up the best Stephen King
adaptations a lot of times they kind of
forget about that one and that was a
shame because I really really do like
that which one Christine yeah like I
said I think a lot of that has to do
with Carpenter's Direction and a lot of
it has to do with the casting I really
really like the cast of that movie I
think they really [ __ ] nailed it well
it shot well that's low lighting and
then the car with the [ __ ] gleam on
the car the headlights and just the way
it was shot the nighttime driving scenes
it Christine's a one has aged real well
it's a classic movie yeah I like that
one it's a classic movie so don't expect
the modern movie but it's it's a great
classic movie
I want to say look man I'm a huge
Carpenter fan when Carpenter's on point
it's almost up there it's almost up
there with the thing it's a different
kind of Horror
I take the thing over it but it's like
in terms of quality kind of like the
thing in terms of watchability
I could watch the thing or or or uh
Christine
I've seen Christine like a zillion times
yeah matter of fact right over there I
have a big big poster like the original
uh movie poster from Christine that I've
had for years and years and to answer
your question about greasers whether or
not greasers are real troublemakers no
the best I can best I can decide for
based on photographs of the original
people involved a greaser was nothing
more than an American version of a
rocker
but greasers didn't have motorcycles
they had cars instead of motorcycles but
it was a similar kind of situation
similar subculture similar kind of
subculture and they weren't about any
trouble those dudes weren't big or
anything the most trouble they got into
was [ __ ] smoking and cutting class
getting laid at the drive-in which would
have been normal yeah that's what
everybody that's what everybody well
that was like a big deal back then you
know and they looked different but no
the greasers weren't about any trouble
as far as I could tell they weren't they
the adults thought they were all
thuggish but but yeah I think a lot of
that it's probably like you said the
same thing that happened in the 80s with
the punks because everyone said oh well
you look like weirdos so you must be
criminals yeah you know what I mean
that's a lot of people but like I said
most of the time it's not because like I
said if you're gonna be I always it's
always been my uh theory that if you
really want to get it up to some bad
[ __ ] then it would be who for you to
like look as normal as possible because
you can blend in better like if you're
gonna make yourself stand out you're
just like making yourself a Target so
why would you do that if you were like
up to some nefarious [ __ ] I'm just
saying if I were to [ __ ] pit rockers
versus greasers I'd probably give it to
their [ __ ] rockers because the
British rockers at least they look like
they had a little bit more physicality
behind them they were riding motorcycles
pry more fighting experience
American greasers [ __ ] if you see him
walking around with that shirt it's all
they look like [ __ ] Danny from
[ __ ] Greece you know [ __ ] John
Travolta little bitty arms and stuff
these aren't Fighters
they're just like Puck rockers yeah
about like that
Danny Rowling says the Night Flyer now
see that's another Stephen King
adaptation I don't think I've seen the
Night Flyer is it good or bad because I
see people bring it up like in both
contexts and I'm not really sure he also
brings up riding the bullet which yeah I
actually kind of uh like that one
and he also says Tommyknockers is worse
than Sleepwalkers yeah I agree I agree
and honestly Tommyknockers I didn't even
like that book I finished it but I
remember not really liking the book all
that much he said he meant langleyers
not Tommy Knox blank leaders because I
didn't know that they made a movie
without Tommy Tommy Knox they did yeah I
think it was also made for TV I read the
book and the book was atrocious I didn't
like the book it was it was uh the
Tommyknocker book was [ __ ]
indecipherable you just couldn't follow
it it was just jumping all over the
place they did have some cool [ __ ] about
the aliens some cool descriptions of the
aliens and stuff but they never the the
story never really jailed I mean
King was on some serious [ __ ] I don't
know what drugs he was on but he was
just although he couldn't hold it
together in in Stephen King's defense
he wrote entire novels and short stories
that like his prodigious output and a
lot of that he was like coped up to the
gills and drunk or drunk and or drunk at
the same time and the fact that he was
able to put together coherent novels
yeah I mean props I would not be able to
do that for sure Tommy Knox no way
wasn't coherent from what I remember it
was jumping all I remember it being
coherent but I didn't really I mean I
haven't read it for a long time I didn't
remember it being like what the [ __ ] is
even going on I don't even know if it
was just like because I'm not a big fan
of like horror that's alien based you
know what I mean other than some
exceptions obviously like Ridley Scott's
alien and the thing and stuff like that
but I don't usually like ooh Alien
Invasion type movies like I said there
are exceptions but they're not usually
my favorite bad King wrote a lot of good
[ __ ] he did
um some of it wasn't that good I mean
not all it especially the later stuff
that I really couldn't get into some of
it and then I just kind of stopped
reading him
I think his best stuff was probably the
Gunslinger series I thought that was
really good
and but even kind of above that my
favorite book that I mean [ __ ] he had a
lot of stuff I'm gonna say one of his
best books was a was a he co-co-wrote
with Peter Straub called the Talisman
yeah I really like that one and they
never did a sequel to it and they never
really they did they did one called the
black house is that what it's called
okay I didn't read it
I probably would have liked it but uh
they never made a movie about it it made
a good movie yeah I don't think they
would have made a good series Strangely
I don't think I mean I'm sure they'll
get around to it that'll be a really
good miniseries I'm sure they'll get
around too yeah
um but no man the [ __ ] the stand was
really good uh just you know his solo
[ __ ] was really good when he was on
point
The Shining was really good just you
know I mean pretty much all of his early
books were pretty good I mean the short
stories were really good and like I said
I'm a big fan of his short stories as
well
um and I had read a lot of his more
recent [ __ ] until I read
um Revival which came out in 2014 and
that was excellent I liked that a lot I
really kind of wish they'd make that
into a movie the first one that that I
came across that I read and I was like
this one's not good it was Tommy
knockers yeah I didn't love Tommy yeah
that was the first one I was like this
is I didn't love I'm trying to think of
like some other books of his that I read
that I didn't love like I said I didn't
love from a Buick 8 I didn't love dream
catcher but then but dream catcher the
book was okay but the movie was awful
yeah
that is like the prime example of [ __ ]
that works in a book don't put it in a
movie because it's not gonna work the
same what was Innovative about [ __ ]
King is that he had his own Universe
long before this [ __ ] DC [ __ ] this
MCU and all that kind of [ __ ] hell no
pretty much all of those books are
interlocked with each other if it
happens in a Stephen King book it's
happening in the same universe I know
there's a guy that mapped it all out I
was going to send you that video yeah
there's really out of everything that he
wrote there's only like one or two of
them that do not reference anything else
out of everything but they still could
be in the same universe just that
there's no references linking it to
anything else
because all the other books reference
other books
in places
Jeff yard said the original Salem's Lot
still holds out as pretty solid yeah I
agree yeah uh and I have a special place
in my heart for Needful Things I do too
actually I kind of like that I don't
remember that one we just watched that
one not too long ago which one was that
the one about the uh Max bonsai was in
it oh yeah about the shop that like it
gives you like your your greatest desire
yeah remember and Silver Bullet I also
love Silver Bullet
um I kind of want to do uh yeah Daniel
Rowling said cycle of the werewolf would
be a good book review I'll get around to
it I promise because I haven't read it
in a long time
um Oracle said Tom and Jenny Netflix is
adapting the Talisman and the guys who
did stranger things are working on it oh
that's gonna be good because the guys
The Duffer Brothers the guys that do
stranger things they are super in okay
man I [ __ ] called it they're super
interested I called it I I'm a marketing
genius those are actually like the
perfect guys to do it I'm telling you
you still need to watch stranger things
I think you will love it but I know it's
good I've seen certain episodes
this is good but I admit I was missing
the other other stuff I saw it out I
mean you've got to see like the whole
thing to like really get in but no I I
knew that that would make a [ __ ]
awesome mini series yeah it would
because that that that's a great book uh
another one that would make up you know
they did do a stand mini series and it's
good
you could redo that though probably make
it even better even though some a fan
and I forgot who it was sorry somebody
sent me the uh remastered version on
Blue on DVD or Blu-ray it's [ __ ]
gorgeous it looks really good the uh the
stand from the early 90s
it's a good miniseries and Jenny hates
it I don't hate it no no no I'm talking
about Jenny hates the [ __ ]
the other series I like Oh The Shining
The Shining oh okay you I thought you
were still talking about the stand no no
no because you didn't expect it yeah I
was gonna I was gonna back up I said
Jenny hates Jenny hates it but I like
the original uh the team made for TV
stand I like it's shining yeah The
Shining excuse me oh I'm drunk
obviously
of course I like um
the kubrickian movie yeah that's a
masterpiece
but if you hadn't read the book
and and that and the movie mystified you
the the made for TV series kinda is much
much closer to the book
it's visually doesn't look as good you
know because you're not talking about
Kubrick you know
and
it has some cheesy makeup and stuff but
that's it but it is telling the story
of the book
I liked it I liked it but I didn't
expect it to be a Kubrick movie you know
I I was gonna put it on par I expected
it to be kind of like The Stand TV
series I didn't mind the Stan TV series
um it it could have been better
obviously but
I kind of feel like back when it was
made it's just kind of I don't know they
can do so much more nowadays like in
terms of like special effects in terms
of how seriously they take it because I
kind of feel like there's more I don't
know there's just more you could they're
more worried about like getting [ __ ]
right nowadays you know what I mean back
in those days they were just trying to
tell the story get it done with under
budget
but the the made for TV
um shining was
a complete telling of the story it's got
Halloran Halloran lives in it like he
does in the book there's no maze it's
the Hedge animals instead
uh it's got all the halloran's dialogue
from what I remembered of the books most
of it's there
um
it's got all the Tony's dialogue and you
see Tony
see I did not love that yeah I know
that's how it is in the book I know
that's how it is in the book but like I
said stuff that works in a book they
don't work in a movie
much scarier in the Kubrick version but
you got two choices you got two choices
you can watch either the movie or you
could if you want to read the book and
you don't want to watch them but you
don't want to read the book you can
watch the TV if you're doing a book
report you're doing it for school
yeah then watch the mini series right
because it is a lot more accurate yeah
and it kind of don't watch the Kubrick
version because that's you're gonna get
an F yeah right
and then and then the thing is is that
the made for TV series explains a lot of
the stuff that was not explained in the
Kubrick version what you saw in the
Kubrick version happened that did happen
most of it happened in the book it's
just that you don't have the context
which is [ __ ] what really makes it
creepy you know like like Wendy's did
see a dude dressed up in a doggy outfit
in a in doggy pajamas with the [ __ ]
bottom open and he was blowing another
dude she did see that but in the book
you find out exactly who that is or why
that was going down
that's not fun to me though it's like I
don't want to know who that is it's just
it's much creepier if you just see that
and there's no context and you're like
what the [ __ ] well it was creepy in the
book though because it gave you the
context behind those guys and who they
were and what they were doing
and and how and what happened to them
and the old lady in the bathtub of of
her story so you get the backstory to
all those ghosts that you saw they were
bad people
yeah
and the hotel got them they were living
in there
but that old
old lady in the bathtub was opito girl
oh pedo woman
you know and she
had her little 15 year old boyfriend
she was real Rich she had a 15 year old
boyfriend with [ __ ] long hair and
everything and uh she kept him around
because
he stayed around because she was she
bought up a [ __ ] Corvette
and uh
he he ran off
eventually what happened to her he ran
off and left her and she got depressed
and
slit her wrists in the bathtub
but she had been doing that for a long
time she still thought she was 20.
she was just some old Rich nympho
and she was going after Danny
and ghost form
it was just [ __ ] creepy man it's a
creepy [ __ ] creepy concept but like I
said I think it's a lot creepier if you
don't know yeah because then because
like I said you don't have any contacts
creepy old
creepy old women [ __ ]
nymphopito ghosts coming after you
slasher Fred brings up rose red I've
been wanting to re-watch Rose Red for
like the longest time I have the book
over there
um and I read it a couple of times I saw
rose red when it first aired because it
was a mini series too and I remember
really liking it but I haven't seen it
since then so that's another one that's
kind of on my re-watch list
um Danny Rowling said how many people
died in this film Sometimes they come
back
um let's see
three of the students
died
even though interestingly I've this is
another difference from the original
short story to the movie in the movie
um chip who's like the jock
in the class
um in the movie he gets killed and like
dismembered there's a very funny
unintentionally funny scene where the
car like the the Hood's car is like on
the bridge and they're like throwing all
of his body parts like out like into the
water and I just like laughed um because
I was like they were clearly like really
late so I thought that was really funny
but in the short story you don't know if
you assumed that chip died but you don't
um see it happen like he just disappears
and nobody knows what happened to him so
there's that so so the three students
died and I think like the the fourth or
fifth guy that was like the hood that
stabbed the brother like back in the day
who actually lived even though all the
others oh that's another difference too
that I forgot in the movie
after
um all the bullies like stab the brother
then a train like immediately comes and
hits and like kills all of them except
for the one guy that ran away
in the story
um that doesn't happen they do die but
they die later like a month after the
murder like they get they're being
chased by the cops or something and they
hit a pole and they all die like in the
car so they changed that uh from the
story to the movie too I totally
forgotten about that Jeff yard said rose
red mini series is fun to watch I
remember it being really good it was
kind of like wasn't it kind of like his
take on Haunting of Hill House right I
mean
so and I'm always down for that because
man I love Haunting of Hill House that's
one of my favorite books of all time
and I loved the Mike Flanagan series as
well that's another guy that does good
Stephen King [ __ ] is Mike Flanagan
because he did Doctor sleep and I will
give Mike Flanagan oh and he also did
um Gerald's Game on Netflix which was
great but the thing about it I will give
Mike Flanagan props because the movie Dr
sleep I liked the movie better than the
book
I didn't love Dr sleep the book
the theatrical cut of Dr sleep yes
mediocre it was okay
the director's cut when you get it on
Blu-ray is a lot better
I really like the tractors so that's not
on Flanagan that was the cut he wanted
but the studio cut a lot of that [ __ ]
out and when they cut a lot of that [ __ ]
out they cut the the the the little uh
the little uh black girl they cut most
of her [ __ ] Abra Abra yeah they cut
most of her character out of the [ __ ]
um of the theatrical release well it's
kind of restored
in the uh director's cut because
remember we did we reviewed the the the
theatrical cut and I was like yeah I
didn't really like the little black girl
I mean why was she there there was you
know what I mean she was just kind of in
there for window dressing and it wasn't
much for that character no there was
it's just that it got cut out for time
well yeah she's the main character she's
the main character in the book but she
isn't all that mean in the theatrical
it's like split halfway between her and
grown-up Dancing Yeah
yeah well I'm saying in that theatrical
cut you're questioning why she's even in
this movie but if you see the director's
cut it makes a lot more sense why she's
in this movie because she they restored
a lot of her scenes and a lot of her
lines
so that was one thing that got better
and then uh
it was more about Danny being Dr sleep
and the people dying
there that wasn't that wasn't originally
in the theatrical cut no they cut that
out of the theatrical cut
so there was more of him to be in Dr
sleep in the uh director's cut
they just had to cut [ __ ] out for time
yeah because it's a long ass movie but
it's a long ass book yeah that's why I
kind of feel like a lot of Stephen
King's novels because man he writes some
chunkers I think it's generally better
if you're gonna adapt one of his novels
do a mini series for Christ's sake
because you need it I mean Stephen King
particularly he really likes like all
these big sprawling like subplots and
all these interconnected characters and
it works really well in fiction but when
you're trying to like cram it all into
one hour and a half two hour movie it
doesn't always like work out I kind of
feel like maybe his short stories
I don't know if this is necessarily
always the case but I think like
sometimes his short stories make better
movies well that's for sure the case
with um the body which they made into
Stand By Me but see again that was a
really good director that was Rob Reiner
and that was an excellent excellent
movie but if you've heard bad things
about doctor sleep and didn't see it
because of that
see the director's cut you'd like it you
could you can stream it
and
um if you're a fan of The Shining you
definitely want to see it
um now I've I've read some reviews about
the theatrical cut and they said well it
just turned the they turned the Overlook
into just a cheap uh haunted house no
see the director's cut it's good
Danny has to go back
then he's being chased by basically
these psychic vampires they're vampires
basically
there are some differences but they just
suck the damn psychic soul out of you
the more you suffer the more they like
it
so you had to go to some place where he
could kind of neutralize them I don't
remember exactly what his rationale was
but he's going to fight him in a place
of evil he goes up to the [ __ ]
overlook
and weird [ __ ] happens when he gets in
there it's
it it's haunted as [ __ ]
and uh
The Overlook talks to him
and it's a scene just like in the damn
Gold Room
instead of the [ __ ] uh the guy who uh
instead of Lloyd
Lloyd shows up but it's his dad playing
the character of Lloyd and the dude that
they got
to play Jack it's not Jack Nicholson of
course you know it's a young guy it's
the same age that Jack was when they cut
that flick he did a good job a real good
job I thought it was Henry Thomas yes
the same guy that was in um Haunting of
Hill House the Mike Flanagan yeah series
that guy did a real good job and he was
in uh uh the Psycho movie Psycho 4 where
he played like young Norman Bates that
was the same actor yeah it is yeah he
does a real good job of playing Jack I'm
pretty sure it was Henry and he doesn't
do a Jack Nicholson impression okay
because that that's kind of cheap but it
does for a second you do kind of you do
kind of forget that that's not Jack
Nicholson it's just it's just a good
scene also I really I gotta say too I
really liked um Alex Esso I like her in
everything she was great in starry eyes
but she played uh Wendy like in the
darkness because she looks a lot like
yeah like Shelley Duvall or she was kind
of like channeling her a little bit but
I like her anyway and actually if you
have a shutter and you've been watching
that 101 scary scenes to she's on there
a lot like talking about some of the
scary scenes and stuff but yeah she's
cool I always like her she's in a lot of
horror movies
um yeah uh Danny rolling I said Storm of
the Century that was a good miniseries
you know what I don't think I ever even
read that book
now that I'm thinking about it God
they're so like he writes so much I
can't keep up you know what I mean
because like I said I have other
people's books I gotta read too Steve
you know what I mean um I do want to
like read them but I just don't have
time and Jeff yard said 1922 on Netflix
is also pretty good yeah I liked that
one as well I kind of feel like a lot of
Stephen King's stuff especially his
later stuff it's usually better if it's
not Supernatural like some of his best
stuff is not Supernatural you know what
I mean like Dolores Claiborne and stuff
like that I think is like really good
Henry Thomas was in E.T wasn't he yeah
when he was a kid but yeah he was in um
I'm pretty sure if I remember him
correctly because we just watched doctor
sleep again like a few months ago and
I'm pretty yeah it was almost a year ago
now I think well yeah that was a few
months ago several months ago but I'm
pretty sure that was Henry Thomas
because Henry Thomas was in
Mike Flanagan's Haunting of Hill House
on Netflix like he was one of the main
characters so he works with my clan
again a lot and I think that he played
the Jack Nicholson characters in doctor
Danny goes back and like I said he was
in Psycho four too Danny goes back in
that hotel to [ __ ] confront that [ __ ]
and I'm not even sure I don't think the
power was on what it was it
it was [ __ ] snowing and it was night
time it was [ __ ] spooky in there I
think some of the power was on and it
had been abandoned for a long time
and he goes into the damn Gold Room
and Lloyd appears but it's not Lloyd
it's his dad dressed as Lloyd and he
goes through the whole [ __ ] thing and
does a bunch of [ __ ] spooky [ __ ] to
try to get to try to get Daddy basically
kill himself it's it's a good it's a
good scene
I don't remember all the details but I
was creeped out
it's just the hotel using the image of
his dad or that might have actually been
his dad it's hard to say it might have
been the ghost of his dad
yeah you never remember you never know
never really know
because it can make you see what it
makes you see what you want to see yeah
and a lot of weird stuff happened in
there
you could feel like the evil it's like
shaking in the house or it's kind of
like a humming in there and it's kind of
the camera angles are kind of spinning
like you're disoriented from the fear of
being in that damn place and uh I can
relate man [ __ ] I've been in bad
places
[ __ ] I've never been to bed I can
imagine one being that bad
but you know bad house you know
Samantha said last thing I saw was Gangs
of New York oh yeah that's right he
wasn't that too wasn't he yeah I kind of
feel like he's in a lot of stuff like he
was in a lot of stuff when he was a kid
like when he was younger and but then
and now it seems lately he's in [ __ ]
everything
uh Jeffy says Jeffy art said I think
it's pretty cool that Stephen King can
write Amazing Stories without
Supernatural elements yet you know they
take place in a world where it exists
yeah yeah I mean honestly and you know I
don't want to say that just across the
board because I do actually like a lot
of his uh paranormal or Supernatural
stories but I kind of feel like a lot of
his stuff is really really good when it
doesn't have Supernatural elements like
when it's just human monsters or when
it's just psychological horror like he's
really really good at that best thing
about King's paranormal stuff is that he
wasn't pulling it out of his ass he was
referring to usually 70 60s and 70s era
parapsychology coming out of
universities of his time
which that's what gave him a coherent
narrative
to his view of the Paranormal and
because it was based on that kind of
based on early parapsychology out of
those universities I agree with a lot of
what he says I don't see that it does
happen I'm saying that
a lot of it is possible and some of it
does happen I've seen it but some of
that [ __ ] would theoretically be
possible if this exists then this then
this and this could also exist
theoretically now he starts going down
that way too
I'm not saying it does but there's
certain core things do exist bad places
uh Poltergeist
um
uh ESP uh dreaming true Out of Body
Experience all that all that all exists
but that's all the basic core phenomenon
he'll get into exotic [ __ ] you know
the whole thing about the dead zone yeah
that exists
yeah there was a dude in the Army got
shot in the K-pop while he was at the
range at a ranger and then started
dreaming true and they put him in
they put him in a program to turn him
into a remote viewing and that was all
verified by Congress in a remote viewing
program he wrote a book about it's
called psychic Warrior real good
but his unit was doing things like
spying on the Soviets and [ __ ] using
remote viewing trying to figure out
where they were making or what the
submarines that they were making looked
like stuff like that
but yeah I mean the the thing you were
saying what I was saying about
um really really liking his short
stories and really liking uh you know
stuff that he wrote without Supernatural
elements I'm just like looking over here
at my little night shift copy here which
like I said I've obviously read like a
zillion times and honestly I think the
best stories in here are the ones that
don't have Supernatural elements like
the ledge or quitters Inc or the last
rung on the ladder like those are like
really really good stories and there's
nothing they're not ghost stories or
anything but I mean his Supernatural
shit's good too but I don't know it's
just I kind of feel like when he goes
too far out there like as with
Supernatural it gets to a point where
it's not really believable and I think
that's an issue that they have too with
like some of the adaptations of his work
is that sometimes you know when he goes
like way out there with Supernatural
[ __ ]
you know yeah you can get away with it
in a book but then when they show that
happening in a movie
um people are not gonna buy it you know
what I'm saying so maybe that's kind of
the issue that I have with it daddy says
yeah self-driving goblins semi-trucks
are plausible well
no some of the [ __ ] he'll he'll he some
of the [ __ ] he did he'd [ __ ] kind of
uh get into the very [ __ ] exotic
paranormal stuff he likes haunted cars
and haunted machines haunted machines
like The Mangler right I like that story
the movie wasn't great but um actually
the movie was kind of terrible but the
story is actually pretty good if a place
can be haunted or if a place can be bad
and a person can be possessed by an evil
spirit can a machine that's what he's
that's what he's hypothesizing and if a
machine can become possessed what does
it do
but I don't think anyone's ever reported
anything like that but he is using a
parapsychology as kind of like a a basis
for what he's talking about and the
thing about it it's like as much as I
like the Trope of like I like Haunted
House movies I like cursed book and
movie stories but there comes a point
where it just gets like ridiculous was
like cursed XYZ you know what I mean oh
it's you know it's a haunted phone booth
it's a haunted you know I don't know
matrushka doll it's a whatever the [ __ ]
it is it's like after a while I'm just
kind of like run out yeah that's what
I'm saying and I kind of feel like he's
done at least two well actually kind of
more like three but he did two stories
that are about essentially haunted cars
like I said Christina did from Bill gate
and you could argue that his short story
trucks which they made Maximum Overdrive
from and I think they made an adaptation
of it that was called trucks as well
although I haven't seen it but that's
also kind of like haunted cars although
that's kind of like haunted everything
that's kind of like
right I mean that was something that
like took like the all the machines
because it wasn't just cars right it was
the coffee maker and the uh you know the
the power knife or whatever yeah because
that's you didn't see Maximum Overdrive
no I don't think I ever saw Maxima I
yeah you probably like Maximum Overdrive
it's ridiculous and also quite awesome
okay I remember this now it's like a
wrestling match I remember this now it's
so funny what I did was I rented that
yeah and a whole bunch of other ones
and I got like [ __ ] 15 or 20 minutes
into it and I pulled that [ __ ] out
that's what it was like I ain't watching
that and put it something else it's so
fun though that's that that's how that
went down I mean it's ridiculous I
really saw it and I and that was like um
that was like Stephen King is like at
like Peak coqued out phase yeah because
he directed it too and even like the
commercials for it you could tell that
he was like coped out of his [ __ ]
gourd and it was so awesome but it's
just like you just got like just blaring
like [ __ ] AC DC the whole movie and
it's just like it's ridiculous and it's
like super super fun but I mean it's not
a good movie but it's still like fun to
watch it's really entertaining just
because it's like so [ __ ] now the
story is actually a lot more restrained
but yeah in the story there's some kind
is it what the [ __ ] is it I can't
remember like what causes it it's like
some kind of Comet or something I guess
it doesn't really matter it doesn't
matter but that sort of thing where
um pretty much like all the machines
like rise up and like against the human
so it's not just cars and trucks it's
also like your refrigerator it's
everything you know what I mean so
haunted everything
yeah uh that was the only film he ever
directed I think yeah after that they
were just kind of like okay Steve you
just yeah you go back over there and
just write your books all right because
we're not we're not giving you like
millions of dollars to like direct a
movie anymore he was probably bouncing
around the set like at least he didn't
direct Lawnmower Man
yeah we'll see now that I ripped that
one off of him I think didn't he yeah
well what happened with that um and that
actually that story is in here as well
the movie that they made of lawnmower
man which was when did that come out
early 90s right it's terrible I was in
the Army it had absolutely nothing
nothing to do with the story they just
wanted the title
and the all that was in there was it was
like the title and then the the fact
that it was like kind of a dumb guy that
was like pretty much it and then it was
like virtual reality I'm like what the
[ __ ] does that have to do with anything
it has absolutely nothing to do with
story the story is actually good the
story is actually like it's really
really short it's only a few pages and
but it's after the story is actually
pretty creepy so they made that and then
Stephen King probably decided he's like
what the [ __ ] is this this isn't my
[ __ ] story so he sued so like to have
his name taken off of it
you know because it's obviously nothing
to do with store I don't know what the
[ __ ] they were thinking
Maximum Overdrive has Lisa Simpson yeah
that's what I was going to say it has a
yearly Smith she's the one that does
that I never heard of Lisa Simpson who's
that from The Simpsons the TV show oh
the cartoon yeah I never really watched
it
oh my God I didn't watch television I
was in the army during that time it's
still on I think it's been on for like a
billion I haven't watched TV in [ __ ]
10 years 15. I mean I've seen it so I I
kind of feel like The Simpsons has been
around so long it's just like seeped
into like because of cultural osmosis
like I haven't seen it in years but it's
like I've seen a lot of the episodes
just by accident you know what I mean
because it's just kind of like kind of
everywhere and it's like memes and
everything like that but yeah yearly
Smith is uh is in it as well which is
funny because you don't usually see her
uh outside of her
outside of her uh voice
uh let's see I wanted to like Maximum
Overdrive because the Green Goblin semi
truck but I couldn't wait for it to be
over it is like I said it is it's very
clear that somebody
um on cocaine made it that's that's what
I'm gonna say very very clear
in the mood for it but I think it is
like kind of entertaining but it's a lot
it's a lot uh to put up with
uh so Jeff yard said wow that's like
saying who's Mickey Mouse that's what I
was thinking that's what I kind of like
was doing that's why I was taking him
back I am very detached from a lot of
American culture you know I mean I was
either gone or in other countries or or
just not paying attention and just and I
was never really a part of mainstream
culture I mean I'll go on um
I'll go on the internet today and I'll
see all these little blurbs and little
ads that pop up from celebrities and
rappers and [ __ ] and I don't know who
those people are
and you could I could probably go back
15 years and I wouldn't know how
wouldn't know those people well I don't
know who a lot of people are nowadays
just because I mean other than because
like I said I'm very very into horror so
I know all that kind of stuff like I
know who all the horror actors are and
all that kind of [ __ ] but as far as like
kind of but I mean I didn't know that
but but the weird thing about it is that
I think it's easier to do that nowadays
because like I said it's easier to focus
on just stuff that you like and there's
like tons of other [ __ ] going on out
there I kind of feel like in the 80s and
90s it was harder to avoid because there
was like this big
mainstream culture that you know you
kind of like knew about even if you
weren't really a part of it so I kind of
know a lot of stuff from back then even
if it was stuff that I didn't like but
nowadays I think it's a lot more
forgivable to like not know [ __ ] that's
gonna like not know who some big famous
person is just because yeah there aren't
any famous people hardly anymore I mean
there are but um but people are famous
in particular niches niches and it's
like if you're not in that Niche then
people are like oh well that's not your
thing so you don't know who that is I
think I think it's funny that there are
Hollywood star stars that make a lot of
money that aren't aren't even known
anymore they're not they're not even
very famous
like there are no Hollywood stars
anymore
you didn't notice that I mean there
still are but like I said it's not the
same as it was nowhere near whatever
it's not like like what it was because
like I said everything's just kind of
like you know it's not it's also like in
the music industry it's the same thing
okay like in uh in metal or in rock
you're never really gonna beat the
numbers of [ __ ] Judas Priest Iron
Maiden [ __ ] all the classics you know
the new bands appear and they can't even
compete with the old ones in terms of
just
sheer pulling power well like I said I
think some of it too is that you know we
have so many more choices nowadays back
in the old days there was just kind of
like mainstream culture subculture that
was about it like nowadays there's 50
bajillions soap is jacked because
tomorrow I think it's tomorrow she's
gonna go see Iron Maiden
so you have people in their 20s late 20s
early 30s
still going to see Iron Maiden and
they're huge shows
you know and there's probably better and
newer metal acts out there because I may
have really kind of played out you know
um they got very stale
but they're just cultural icons now you
know
and she she saw uh Judas Priest and she
had never really even heard and she was
Priest album because her uncle took her
to go see it she [ __ ] just loved it
Rob Halfords up and she's sending me
clips of her looking at Rob Halford to
go yeah it's God she's like what this is
God his name is God [ __ ]
Rob Halford's [ __ ] trademark name is
metal god
and she just started thought that she
was funny because yeah he [ __ ] sings
good you know
Gilded Age Phoenix said the lawnmower
man came out during the mentally
deficient main character era in the film
Forrest Gump Rain Man Gilbert Grape
Sling Blade yeah there were a lot of uh
there were a lot of those coming out
around that time now like I said in the
story at least from what I could
remember like the main character was
kind of like a mentally deficient guy
but other than that there was absolutely
nothing to do with which I don't know
why they thought they could get away
with that and why would you even call it
the lawnmower man that just doesn't have
anything to do with virtual reality I
don't get it I don't get it I don't know
what the [ __ ] they were they must add
some better cocaine than Stephen King
had at that time it's just a cash crab
um uh Daniel Rowling said malignant
ripped off an episode of The X-Files
with the Florida Citrus freak Town yeah
I mean I liked malignant a lot of people
didn't like it but
um they're talking about terrifier too I
do I actually want to see that because I
really really liked uh the first
terrifying because it was good that was
like super fun yeah I mean it's been a
while since uh the first one came out
but I mean I like the first one I did
too I liked it a lot it was like it was
a blast but yeah that movie had class
man it had [ __ ] style I remember do
you remember we watched it um I think
Shawna and Eric were over and we all
like watched it in living room we just
like we had a [ __ ] oh man that was a
who I know yeah we were just like we had
some drinks and some popcorn and [ __ ]
like that we had the [ __ ] basket it
took me back to the 80s or the 90s back
when those movies had Soul we were all
like howling and stuff like wow look at
that
it was like so fun it was so fun uh but
yeah all right so I guess we're gonna
wrap it up we've been on for more than
an hour uh so somebody and I think it
was you Danny rolling but now it's not
there anymore
uh because tomorrow is our haunting
Mondays show and we're sitting here
going well what episode are we gonna do
Danny Rowling said we should do the
Wheat Sheaf horror okay so maybe we
should do that I think we've done that
one no we haven't okay um because yeah
that was one that I kind of been meaning
to do so yeah I was I was hoping
somebody would give me an idea because
we have there's so many we have like so
many but yeah we'll do that one then and
if we change our mind I'll I'll post it
and I'll post it again tomorrow in case
uh but yeah we'll do the Ouija horror
tomorrow but yeah so thanks for dropping
by and hanging out with us today talking
about Stephen King among various other
things and uh we'll see you guys again
tomorrow at 6 p.m Eastern Standard Time
for a haunting Mondays so hopefully you
can all make it and we'll see you then
goodbye